on the hill tonight for the giants will
be
the right-handed veteran aaron sanchez
such as 28 years old
in his sixth year at the big league
level 6 for 210 pounder
and a very loose arm delivery his
velocity will be
between 91 and 93 miles per hour so
here's winker and
slowly hit tough play for crawford he's
going to throw on the run
and he got him what a play degree of
difficulty almost impossible
oh my lord and remember winker could run
i mean crawford had to come a long way
to his right
and from the cross body slings it over
to first base and flores puts the the
glove on it they do indeed get winker
castiano's 12 for 37.
there's that curveball it's got some
english on it not a problem
two down here's joey votto six for 37.
about 85 hits shy of three of 2 000.
he'll get that this year
curveball you're gonna miss and that'll
end the inning
wade miley makes start two his last on
tuesday against the pirates the 250th of
his career
and his best in a reds uniform he was
really good
reaching swing a force pull short way
double play a touch tardy solano reaches
the rough creeps up on the plate little
jam nice play by suarez shovel for one
double play wade miley just being miley
ground ball gideon zenzel who's eight
for 23.
the 1-0 pitch center field dubai
side retired
[Applause]
buster lines at the left he's got a base
hit
circling under it is winker
and the giants have their first hit and
actually it's the first hit of the game
for either team
he went down and got this one ball drops
down right
at the knees middle end suppose he's not
waiting around
he's looking for one thing one type of
movement gets it makes a pay
count of zone one right-handed hitter
nothing nothing here in the second two
down posey at first
oh nice play by mustache long
nice play all the way around what a
glove by mustaches
but he kept that foot on the bag wow
what a play
one pitch one out here in the third
there's a four pitch walk i think for
any hitter when you're barreling the
ball with some semblance of regularity
it gives you great confidence at the
plate so you see the ball better because
you're not so jumpy you're not worried
about all right can i get my hands to
this
to the zone there is an infectious
celebratory
fun sense of emotion about jesse winker
3-1 uppercutted pretty decent carry
de bone in retreat gone
home run jesse winker and the reds take
a two-nothing lead
well i would say that provides a bit of
excitement sanchez goes back to that
pitch
but he doesn't start it off the plate he
starts it on the plate
a hitter sees it on the plate it's go
time and it runs back middle end
gone and that goes into the more freshly
minted bullpens
brandon crawford the lone lefty in the
full nine
tonight he goes out here looking he
disagrees that looked like a great pitch
from way to milo
the 2-2 pitch sanchez strikes out
swinging
change-up got him so two down
back-to-back strikeouts for wade miley
two nothing reds
outside check swing he wins
three up three down all by way of k
two nothing reds want to get hit by this
thing but if he hangs it i can hit it
and he throws you that
here's a little dribbler barnhart
gathers tough play
makes the throw solano claims second one
out
it's the whole process of pitching for
wade miley as you see barnhart get to
that ball
barehanded did not put the glove down at
all
you bare hand it you get the feet set
and trust your arm to beat the runner if
you can make a hitter
choose to swing at that pitch it makes
the plate so much bigger
goes back up backhand pick one-footed
throw suarez has made a few of those
on this road trip castiano says a hit a
line drive
baits it rolls this one over to crawford
on the run throw got him new pitcher for
the giants two-nothing reds
joey vado left-handed hitter against the
left-hander
and there joey vano into the bay
a splashdown for his first homer of the
year
mccovey cove be joey votto
three nothing reds well that was a no
doubter
you'll see a smile on joey votto's face
i like that
i guess he was tired of hitting the line
drives and one hoppers to the second
baseman
he just hit it over everybody
three-nothing reds
each team entered at six and three that
pitch
blasted pretty deep left center
at the wall senzelle well that is three
balls tonight
that evan longoria has hit two of which
if we were playing at great american
ballpark would have been home run
nick senzelle egging the crowd on if you
talk to outfielders
visiting outfielders this is one of the
place where they say
fans are just brutal they will ride you
the entire
game it looks like with a brandon bell
pinch hitting here
there's a swing of the miss tj antone
continues to deal
he takes strike three call the fastball
on the inside down around the knees oh
man what a filthy pitch
and that ball right to suarez in perfect
position
two up two down he had 35 ribbies in the
short year
last year bit of a reaching swing nice
pick by vatto antone on the cover
antone three scoreless innings tj antone
is out for the night
solano not held on pull shift on the
infield
outfield deep
payoff runner goes hard ground ball and
the shift works perfectly
farmer gathers flips tovato go ahead and
take second donovan solano
two outs and he gives way to lucas sims
solano off second base belt the tying
run on deck
sims ready 2-2 swing and a miss he
struck him out
ball game reds and they take down the
giants in shutout fashion what a spark
to the series
3-0 cincinnati